i ain't afraid of no ghost
of course not you're in the ghostbusters
universe
with a quick stop
demons are as good as gone
so
how would life change if you could bust
ghosts in real life
would you need to reinvent nuclear power
or just need a whole lot of money
and
could you get slimed
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you could trap a ghost like
the ghostbusters
in the new movie ghostbusters afterlife
a spooky tradition gets passed on to the
next generation
this family has been using science to
catch ghosts since the 1980s
but the concept is nothing new
ghost busting revolves around
electronegativity
that means you'll be using positively
charged atoms to attract negatively
charged particles
you'll need heavy duty power for this
job
remember that in the films they use
particle accelerators working at close
to the speed of light
but how would you keep this pack from
exploding
in the original ghostbusters movie the
team wore portable particle accelerators
called cyclotrons
these devices used a constant high
frequency voltage contained by a
magnetic field
now you would be using something called
a synchrotron
this device would use super conducting
magnets to create the laser whip needed
to lasso a ghost
but what's inside this pack
to catch a ghost you'd need to emit a
particle stream of protons along with
raw nuclear energy
to do that you would have to use liquid
helium cooling systems to keep the
superconductors at about minus 270
degrees
in these films the spirits consist of
psychokinetic energy
and their energy has a negative charge
so when this positively charged beam
shoots out these floating nightmares can
be dragged into a positively charged
laser grid
we'll talk about that trap later
right now let's focus on catching that
ghost without getting slimed
when that hungry ghost hit actor bill
murray it left behind a mess of slime
that the movie called ectoplasm in the
real world ectoplasm doesn't exist but
ghostbusters universe ectoplasm has a
negative charge which the proton stream
could trap
just keep your distance
uh it won't come off my hand
some amateur engineers have designed
cyclotrons only eight centimeters in
diameter
but that wouldn't be enough for you to
bust a ghost
maybe you could use the energy produced
by the large hadron collider
one of the most powerful particle
accelerators ever made
much larger than an angry marshmallow
man
this monster is three times the size of
mount everest
the particle accelerator's ring
stretches almost 27 kilometers
underground and
super conducting magnets line the inside
this scientific achievement cost
billions of dollars but
that one on your back
well that'll run you around
nah
125
bad
now let's talk about what you're wearing
we're going to call the nerds
this jumpsuit might be a classic but
without proper protection the radiation
from that laser could damage your dna
and you might develop cancer in the long
term
right now
get out of the way
this beam could instantly rip apart the
atoms of anything in its path and if you
crossed two of these streams it could
lead to every molecule exploding at the
speed of light
total protonic reversal
that's bad hey watch where you're
pointing that
once the trap door opens look away
the positively charged radiation your
pack emitted would bring out
nanoparticles called muons
these dense negatively charged atoms
would weigh down the ghost as the trap's
positive charge would draw them inside
and if the radiation hasn't killed you
yet
close that door
with careful precautions you might have
what it takes to go head to
skull
with the undead
so now that you've mastered super
conducting magnets oh my gosh maybe
you're ready to take on a different
movie franchise
what if you built a lightsaber
all right i've been waiting for this for
so long
oh wait oh you're still here
sorry
that's a story for another
what if
[Music]